who are the owners who are the minority
owners we know the stein brenners have
the controlling stake well there's a
host of minority-owned there's limited
partners in the team we don't know who
is selling this particular steak though
but we did get the teaser that it's out
there that teasers are central bankers
who might have clients for the purchase
so we got a hold of that we do know
what's on the market we just not sure
who share of the team it is how do you
market 1% of the Yankees and can more
than one person bid or is this going to
be sold as a complete entity in itself
so this like an auction sure if more
than one bitter wants to get in on this
they'd love to drive the price up yeah
how do you been on it can will they
split the one percent no no no this is
velvel sell before one percent as is but
it's the New York Yankees there's myriad
reasons why people would like to be
involved just say they own a piece of
the most prestigious North American
sports team out there exception that's
the egg one yeah some some LPS use it as
a training ground for a future purchase
of a majority ownership of a team some
use it in their core business they think
it's cool to be able to close a business
deal maybe in center field or bring them
in the clubhouse it's something else
they can do that their competitors can
so there's plenty of reasons steaks I
imagine don't come up two of them they
come up every now and then for the
Yankees because there's estate planning
issues so people do dump either a piece
of their steak or the whole thing every
now and then but a full one percent of
the Yankees what's most interesting
yellow is the valuation of the team you
get a glimpse into the valuation of the
club so there it's been marketed as 300
billion dollar franchise our million
dollar franchise write a three billion
dollar franchise three billion dollar
sorry three billion dollar franchise and
the portion 24 million explain how we
came to that that's a 20-percent
discount the seller is offering a
20-percent discount because it's a
limited stake now LPS and pro sports
team does a famous quote from John
McMullen who used to be an LP in the
Yankees years ago under George
Steinbrenner when he said nothing is
more limiting than being a limited
partner to George Steinbrenner you don't
get a lot of say in operations sometimes
you don't even get tickets believe it or
not you could pay and not even get
tickets so it's really it's a play in
the prestige fact you say I have this as
an asset but because of that it's being
discounted by twenty percent that brings
you down to two point four billion then
one percent of that there you go 24
million dollars yeah now you nothing to
do with the YES Network
they're right nothing to do with the
Yankee Stadium nothing to do with the s
network which is majority-owned by Fox
these days though this is just strictly
the team as an asset all right well any
uh any clues as to who might be wanting
to bid no we don't know yet now that
it's on the market and people know about
it I don't know why they we're trying to
keep it quiet to begin with if you want
to sell something but more more bidders
means a higher price but you can be sure
there will be plenty of interest because
it is the ink well I'm sure you'll find
out for us